figure skating's not real it's not a
real sport anyways who gives a [ __ ] oh
coming from the diver come on i can say
that do you guys know who apollo ohno is
no
don't you don't even yes don't say it
yes no saying figure skating is not real
it's rich coming from the two guys that
look like they crawl out of apollo's
face i know his face i just feel like
he's you're lying every character on snl
like any person could fall into the
costume closet and come out looking like
him he's a figure skater
yeah
he was a speed skater he looks fast he
looks like if kid rock was doing speed
so just kidding okay he's going back on
tour and he was like i'm gonna pull on
my dates if there's any covered
restrictions and everyone's like at the
like pig and a whistle bar like who's
going to the kid rock show i was
thinking you meant chris rock and i was
like i am not kind of getting that
from that image kid rock actually said
if there's coveted restrictions i'm not
performing
bummer and i was so pumped to see kid
rock like there's anyone at those shows
that's there unironically yeah right no
dude people love kid rock
yeah
yeah no singing sweet home alabama right
remix it or something
it's the same one you were just singing
no that's exactly yeah
we're talking about kid rock i'm talking
about the exact same thing you're
talking about those are two different
people they're not the song we were
singing is the exact same you guys are
wondering what the show is like
have you ever watched your siblings
fight if you're a middle child this will
be very enjoyable we have the show for
you are you arguing about the fact that
kid rock remixed sweden home alabama i'm
honestly i lost what we were i was
arguing you started singing would you be
able to sing that again all summer long
and i was singing the exact same song
she was singing sweet home alabama no
sweet singing
alabama
yeah i'm sorry he does sample from
sweden alabama by leonard skinner
in that song but at the end of the day i
was right and so connor's the one who's
going to be pissed when they pull when
he pulls the show yeah the covert
restriction
i really wanted to hear your remix of
sweet home alabama
northern michigan to go see that show at
the ugly duckling bar
and there's only one flight a day that
goes there you [ __ ] [ __ ]
brook can you bring the mic oh yeah i'm
sorry bringing more closer to my house
yeah sorry so let's talk next let's talk
about bringing the mic closer to her
mouth